have you noticed that it is usually
exciting to learn something at the
beginning but because it takes effort
and time you tend to easily give up
there are so many things to learn and
you feel overwhelmed
you've been trying to improve your craft
but then comes the next shiny thing
trying to steal your attention away
and the results
outputs that you are hardly satisfied
with just for the aim of producing
something
if you want to achieve better than
average results you need to step up your
game
the thing is that in order to remain
valuable in our economy you must master
the art of quickly learning complicated
things
this task requires deep work
if you don't develop this ability you
will likely fall behind as technology
advances
in a nutshell if you cannot learn you
cannot thrive
no matter how skilled or talented you
are
have you ever worked on a project that
demands your full focus like debugging
some code writing an article designing a
presentation or building out a strategic
plan
and totally lost track of time because
you were so engaged on completing this
task
this awesome experience has been coined
as a flow state which can be best
described as functioning completely in
the zone
flow states are best achieved during
deep work where you are dedicated and
focused on a single task for an extended
chunk of time and can really get into
the problem at hand
it's in these deep work sessions when we
are the most innovative creative and
significantly more productive
in other words professional activities
performed in a state of distraction free
concentration or deep work can push your
cognitive capabilities to their limit
these efforts create new value improve
your skill and are hard to replicate
opposite of this is what is called a
shallow work which does not create much
new value and often can be performed
when you are distracted
shallow type of work can be writing an
email answering a call cleaning your
office desk or any other quick to do
duty
most people spend their days doing
shallow work
and it's often these low value tasks
that keep us from more important higher
value projects that require deep work
for example have you ever been trying to
focus on a big project and been
distracted by a trivial email that you
felt you needed to respond to
immediately
obviously it is incredibly difficult to
completely remove these types of
distractions from your life especially
in the modern office environment
and there's a major reason why we're
more attracted to these types of tasks
they're quick and easy and give us a
sense of accomplishment
in the long term however they're holding
us back from bigger career and life
goals
so what can you do about it
the thing is that the deep work isn't
about working harder or longer
it's about working smarter
ideally deep work is about transforming
your work days from a random series of
reactive events into a well-oiled
schedule that allows you to prioritize
the highest value tasks
deep work is more than just a set of
good habits it's a skill that needs to
be learned
it's like playing the guitar something
you wouldn't expect to be good at unless
you actually practiced and trained for a
long period of time
it's important to emphasize that because
a lot of people think about deep work
more like a habit such as flossing their
teeth
that might sound scary but it isn't
here are 4 simple steps you can take to
begin a deep work regime today step 1
schedule time for deep work
reclaiming your focus means exercising
control over your schedule
start planning out your weeks and block
out sections of time for deep work
the best way to do it is to alternate
between sessions of deep work and more
menial tasks on a single day
you see the average person has about
four to five hours per day of the focus
time in them and is only truly
productive for about three hours per day
this is why you want to maximize your
most productive time for deep work on
high priority high value tasks while
also reserving time to stay on top of
your shallow work duties
the most important thing to remember is
that you're training yourself to reach a
state of deep concentration so you need
to be disciplined in sticking to your
routine
step two create a distraction-free
environment
there is an element of self-discipline
that comes into play when performing
deep work
as you know distractions come in all
shapes and sizes from phones to
co-workers to kids and you're going to
want to get rid of them all
if you work in an open plan office
consider booking a private room or
working from home if you can
if the internet is a problem for you
switch off your phone and disconnect
your laptop
stick to pen and paper or even go to the
local library if you have to just make
sure you have a clear and calm
environment that facilitates deep
concentration
it also helps to associate a particular
location with deep work for example a
different office or even a completely
different building
step 3 embrace rest and relaxation
deep work isn't just about cutting out
distractions so you can focus on big
projects
it's also about getting a good night's
rest and turning up to work refreshed
and relaxed
besides you need to discover your most
effective way of completing deep work
tasks
maybe you find you flow best with a
couple two hour focused work sessions in
the morning and a long lunch break
before diving into shallow work in the
afternoon
or maybe you prefer shorter
distraction-free sessions and mindful
break intervals to rest your eyes and
drink some water
do what feels best for you and know that
maximizing your productivity starts by
taking care of yourself in order to
avoid complications like mental
exhaustion down the line
remember that it's important to give
your body and brain time to recuperate
step four audit your time spent on deep
work and shallow work
deep work is about more than getting zen
at the office
it's about improving your productivity
especially when it comes to high value
goals
create metrics to measure your
productivity and if you can hold weekly
review sessions to keep track of your
progress
during these regular sessions you need
to ask yourself
how many of my planned tasks did i
complete this week
what habits did i make time for
what was left unfinished on my to-do
list by friday afternoon
regularly auditing your calendar can
help give you quantitative insight as to
where your time is going whether it is
aligned with your goals and priorities
and where it may be getting misallocated
it also can help you pinpoint time sinks
say no to things you don't have time for
and minimize daily distractions so that
you can get more of your task list done
and defend your limited time for the
things that are important to you
by tapping into the magic of deep work
and better managing the boring everyday
shallow busy work you can work to find
greater fulfillment in your skill get
more quality work accomplished in less
time and provide an even better value to
your team
as algorithms and robots take on more
and more of the menial everyday tasks
that keep businesses running
employers and clients are going to be
looking to those who can provide real
value to their bottom line
that means those who have prayed
themselves in the art of serious
critical reflection
it's time to dive into the deep end and
tap into your deep work superman or
superwoman if you don't you'll only be
left behind
if you found this video useful i'd
appreciate it if you smash the like
button and click on the notification
bell
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel for more videos like
this in the future